foreign
let's go out to San Fran California and
talk to Marjorie what's up Marjorie
hey Dr John what's up
oh nothing much just putting my business
out there for millions of viewers to
hear
hey man listen listen nobody listens to
this show Marjorie you know that it's
true nobody listens to the show
hey I do there's gonna be dozens of
people dozens dozens so what up how can
I help
so um thank you for taking my calls
um
so uh my question is how do I
how do I emotionally be there for my
daughter while I'm going through grief
um and the backstory is my husband
passed away
um back in April
and so um what was his name
who was Adam Adam
yeah he was all right
he he was all right we had a
Rocky marriage
um he was in
uh he was an addict and so
um
we were separated for the four years
that we were married and so it was kind
of uh
I guess uh
while I was grieving you know through
the whole
ordeal and so
um how did he pass away
um that I'm not sure yet I'm still
waiting for the coroner
uh to release that information okay
um
I'm so sorry that's so recent
how is your baby girl
three three
she know Dad or was there a lot of
separation
um
both she knew him but
um you know there was
kind of a lot of Separation but she
knows you know she sees pictures and
stuff she knows that's her dad yeah
so
what does grief look like for you these
days
um
uh not wanting to do much yeah
and a lot of kind of circular thinking
and not being motivated to do things so
are you working right now
yeah
where do you work
um I am an Urban Farmer
no way for real
you like you like sell like vegetables
and stuff
yeah
what else do you sell
unless they just produce produce awesome
yeah and you do that year round
thank you
um no we don't do it year round just
mostly during the summer in the off
Seasons we kind of just are getting
ready for the
harvest season pretty much okay
so
here's the hard part
is
is a single mom you got to pay your
bills
great you gotta work
you got to make sure your insurance is
paid up you got to make sure those the
lights stay on
you got to make sure that baby girl's
got food
and
you have to honor your body in this
season when it just wants to be quiet
for a while
and so it's a both and
what you're gonna have to do I would say
the most important thing and I'll give
you a list of a couple things that I
think would be really good just to have
check offs on on a note card every day
I'll give you those things but
you're gonna have to switch
your anger and frustration and disgust
that you have with Marjorie
and change that to curiosity
okay because you get really mad at
Marjorie when she don't want to get up
and go work out or if you don't want to
get up and go do whatever Fair yeah
you gotta let her off the hook for a
minute man the love of her life died
the love of her life died
and when you're in love with somebody
who really struggles with addiction
you know this day is coming
and you constantly ask yourself what you
should have done and what you could have
done and so the the shame cycle gets
worse and worse right
right you gotta let Marjorie off the
hook man Marjorie did everything she
could
Marjorie loved that man to the Moon and
back
even when she couldn't even be in the
same house with him because he wasn't
safe
and so when marjorie's body says hey
we're laying right here today
if you got to go to work you gotta go to
work
but I want you to honor yourself okay
okay now
here's a path out
not for suddenly feeling a million times
better anybody who's selling you that is
selling you snake oil okay don't do that
um
but here's the path out
the path out is having a note card that
you fill out the night before
um the next day
and on that note card it's going to say
a couple of simple things one of them is
movement you gotta move
that can be taking your baby girl on a
walk
back in in a stroller that can be taken
her to a park
but you gotta move and the second one is
you got to get sunshine
you live in San Francisco that shouldn't
be too difficult and you're gonna but
it's gonna mean just for a few minutes
you got to get up and get outside
okay all right this is
this is those moments when I don't care
what you feel I want you to just
practice the discipline of I am going to
move today I am going to go outside and
get some sunlight and have a cup of
coffee outside
the third thing is you cannot do this
season by yourself
do you have some women in your life that
you can reach out to that you can talk
to
yeah I have a few
I would love it love it love it if you
had a once a week morning breakfast or a
morning coffee
one of your friends came over to your
house
are you into theirs and brought
knucklehead three-year-old with you
and what will slowly happen over days
and weeks and months is the light comes
back on a little bit
you're always gonna love that guy
and you're always going to be
heartbroken
how are you notified that he passed
um
someone that he was living with help me
okay
can I tell you one more thing
yeah
often when we lose somebody that we love
especially somebody who was hurting
or somebody who got in a car wreck or
somebody who was struggling with
addiction
our brain locks in on the hurt and pain
they were feeling
as though at the time of the wreck at
the time of the assault at the time of
addiction
using
and I wanted you to hear me say now
the atoms at peace
you're not hurting anymore
and for somebody who loved him for as
long as you did that was your that was
that was the dream right is that he
would stop hurting you let him stop
hurting and be with you yes
correct but it's easy to remember how
much he was hurting and to get locked in
there
bro's at peace now Adam's at peace
and hopefully over the next few weeks
next few months you can
have you written him a letter yet
um no all right that's your last
assignment we're gonna get a note card
it's gonna say move it's going to say
outside it's going to say contact a
friend it's gonna say eat okay you got
to make sure you're eating are you
skipping meals
okay we're gonna be a good Steward of of
Marjorie okay
and by the way if you eat a few if you
gain a few pounds over the next few
months it's all good with me okay
um I want you to write three letters
okay here's letter number one letter
number one is
how much you miss Adam Dear Adam I miss
you
tell them what you miss
house and be specific I miss your life I
miss when you were sober and clear-eyed
how much you loved me I missed all the
how funny you were all that
letter number two is Dear Adam I'm so
angry I can't breathe
and let him have it
write down on paper how much you tried
how you went to the ends of the Earth
how he cheated on you how he did this
how he did this how he did this write
all that down
the third note the third letter is
Dear Adam
here's who I'm gonna become
I want you to tell them what kind of mom
you're going to be to his baby girl
I want you to tell him what kind of mom
and woman you're going to be what kind
of business owner you're going to be
start to write down the plans
okay don't do these all on the same day
maybe take a break between them and if
it gets really tough get a counselor
okay
and I want to get some of this some of
these spinning thoughts like you
mentioned the loops I want to get them
out of my head and out of my body and
onto some paper so I can look at them
okay okay okay if you're a real gangster
a real San Fran gangster
um
when one of your friends comes over for
coffee
I want you to say hey I wrote a letter
to Adam can I read it for you
and I want you to read it in front of
somebody else
if you're just a regular gangster then
you can read it in front of a counselor
but saying these things out loud is
really really important
getting them out of your body is super
important but also reading them so make
a note card every night there's a
practice to this there's like a there's
a commitment to this writing it down and
don't just put in your phone on your
notes app write it down on a note card
the night before wake up that day and
just commit to doing those four or five
things and then give your body peace
give your body peace there will come a
time in the next few months when maybe
you don't want to be an Urban Farmer
anymore maybe you want to move maybe you
want to do some other things awesome
let those things come and that's why
you'll have a group of women that you
can bounce some of these ideas off of
you can dream with you can think big
with get some encouragement or some
insights or some wisdom from
but man you're still flat in the thick
of it man I'm so sorry that you lost the
love of your life
we'll be grieving with you Marjorie
thank you so much for the call thanks
for being brave
that little baby's lucky to have you